let's talk about 20th century boys okay
because that is a that is actually a
good manga okay this is my favorite
manga it's brilliant i've never read
this i've been wanting to read this i've
actually got it downloaded ready to read
everything by uh
i can i can give you the manga volumes
instead oh you have them with you yeah
that's in english yeah in english
that's that's the model which is just
gonna read it
well the cover looks badass
so it's [ __ ] amazing so 20th century
boys is my favorite manga of all time
and i've i only read this just before
moving to japan and it's it's it's kind
of like the oh yes me punishment where i
knew i would love this for ages and i
held off reading it until i had just the
right amount of time and the right
mindset and that just so happens when i
had the few week break before i moved to
japan and i was like okay i am now ready
to experience i'm now ready for emotion
and
it lived up to everything and more i
like i i knew it was like a magnum opus
of a piece of work and i still like it's
it's amazing but also it like every
every lesson and every message you try
to say like it spoke to me personally as
well so it was kind of like a mixture of
personally this was my kind of story and
also it's amazing an amazing story this
is this was the manga that made me go
wow uracil is a [ __ ] genius can you
give me a very quick rundown of the sure
sure
okay so it's
oh oh it's pretty complicated applause
it's it's a very give me the most
bare-bones explanation okay so i'll try
to sell you this as quickly as possible
so
um so imagine like when you're growing
up as a kid right you play hero and
villains right
and so
like you you play a hero and someone
plays a hero and someone plays the
villain and normally a super villain
they try to take over the world right
it's a cartoony plot they take of the
world and the hero stops them now what
if you could make this very childish
plot believable
that is basically what 20th century boys
is right sounds cool it's someone who
basically
tries to take over the world and naoki
naoki aristotle went how can we actually
make this actually seem realistic and
terrifying and terrifying as well that's
that's like the bare bones basic premise
of this what i love about this is that
it's kind of like a mystery so it
doesn't open up with that that premise
what it opens up with is this guy who's
just a normal guy who stumbles upon
a conspiracy right
and so
of course you stumble upon a conspiracy
and you see how deep this how deep this
conspiracy goes
yeah yeah exactly exactly
and it the way the story unravels is
that
like you are given pieces just to how
how deep this conspiracy
this conspiracy goes and how far it runs
and the more chapters you read normally
like you see a mystery and like you can
you're able to like kind of get a feel
for like how big this mystery is right
what i find [ __ ] amazing about 20th
century boys is that i was like five to
ten volumes in or something like that
and it felt like i was staring into an
abyss in terms of this mystery like this
this this feeling where you just don't
know how deep this rabbit hole goes like
you you're just like there's no way this
can go deeper and then something gets
revealed and you're like
where does this end
how the [ __ ] how far this does this go
and like the way that and that's what i
find i find that incredible there's no
but no other mystery that's just giving
me this feeling of just like it was kind
of like almost existential dread because
i didn't know how far this sank or how
how deep this went um and it's probably
like it's my favorite manga of all time
i think it's my favorite mystery of all
time
i'm so so amazing at writing these just
mysteries where it's just like you don't
know where it's going and also
i don't know about you but
i feel is a genius at writing
some of the most perfect antagonists
yeah in manga i mean he also did monster
yeah right yeah okay you should have
said that yeah oh yeah yeah it's the
same guy right
same guy
but like monster is like way more
character driven and i think it's like
much more smaller scale this one is like
a [ __ ] massive scale it sucks there's
so much to read now
i'm like this is this is never going to
get an anime adaptation because like
compared to the live action this is yeah
i don't know
it's yeah i mean compared to monster
this this would be like hundreds of
episodes maybe because that's just
that's just how like monster was like
70-something episodes this would easily
be like 150 200 episodes yeah yeah make
it happen honey got over a 148 yeah and
yeah i i feel like it's the greatest
manga i've ever read and it's definitely
up there yeah yeah yeah is there
anything more than that can you give it
a higher praise than that that's that
it's it's my i guess i have to read it
[ __ ] me it's brilliant it's my uh it's
it's it's i i like i can't even pick a
favorite anime of all time but the fact
that i can pick a favorite manga of all
time is telling that's telling ladies
and gentlemen we got him
we got him and it's not domestic
girlfriends
surprisingly in the middle don't [ __ ]
for that
i i didn't put anything significant in
my middle one i just clicked
i mean i should have should have it it
was the oromo square that's why i put it
in the middle